Rosetta had been traveling in space towards a comet...
...called 67P Churyumov-Gerasimenko for ten years.
The journey was long and she fell into a deep sleep...
...that lasted for 2 years, 7 months and 12 days.
But on the 20th of January 2014, with the help of everyone on Earth shouting,...
..."Wake up, Rosetta," she opened her eyes...
...and let everyone back home know she was okay.
There was no time to lose.
All of the experiments that were packed on board had to be woken up...
...along with a lander, Philae.
Before long, Rosetta was able to see the comet in the distance.
She was getting closer and closer, but there were still many challenges ahead.
There were ten maneuvers to complete, but Rosetta was determined.
As she checked them off one by one, the comet got closer and closer.
It was the most wonderful sight that Rosetta had ever seen.